give it up for drama cow
[Applause]
oh no problem
[Music]
our first guest today is one of our
favorites partly because he always
brings a new baby animal every time he's
here I love this his new show
coincidentally is called animal control
and it premieres tonight on Fox give it
up for John McHale everybody
thank you
look at this
it's a sloth this is so happy right
okay can't pet his hand though don't
well I'm fine here you can bet here
[Applause]
[Music]
look look
what's up guys
you're taking him home congratulations
you've won the slot I know I already
warned my team am I going to take a
sloth home yeah oh my god do you want to
hold them I really do all right here we
go well I'll get well hello watch this
is his food which is uh lettuce and
vodka uh if you sit okay okay I'll give
them to you but I'm so excited wait okay
okay this is a tree sloth everybody as
opposed to the okay as opposed to you
know a ground sloth which are extinct oh
that's a great fun fact uh so um yeah if
you uh if you yeah you can give them a
little uh oh look at this check this out
guys God I'm so happy yeah look at that
can you get a read on that look at that
oh do you feel it I can't even see the
joke on my arms I can't wait eighth of a
beer yeah
oh my God I love when you come I like
this one because Kelly doesn't care this
is great because you're like no one who
oh who cares about Jolie's animals it's
just kidding yeah and there you go look
at that guys have you ever seen anything
this cute and
a lot of people think they're uh you
know they smell they don't they don't
smell yeah they smell like Jasmine
Jasmine they don't smell like Jasmine
right now probably because it's hard to
clean themselves they're so slow about
it they're a little slow but you know
they are three times stronger than a
human being and I am not kidding they
can uh they can basically hang from a
tree indefinitely
oh my god let's get to our first guest
though he is very funny very talented I
love him so much I do think he stole a
guitar Off the Wall the last time he was
at our show so he's the Clemson meeting
it's fine
um his new podcast is called Black Box
you can listen on Apple Spotify and
wherever you get your podcast give it up
for John McCain
[Applause]
yeah do you want to feed them yes I hope
this works okay okay their names are
Spider-Man and MJ oh my God I love it
love it and I just named them uh 10
seconds ago
there you go you just there there we are
yeah it's everywhere but it's okay as
you know I'll do anything you're doing
great do I know how to do you clearly
have done this with babies like I mean
you dangle the bottle over them I'm
trying
it makes them wanted I'm trying so hard
do it I'm failing you should try well
it's matcha so I don't know
there you go Bud yeah they use my gosh
where are you going where are you going
Kelly my goal is for you to never ask me
a single question that you'll just be
completely distracted the entire time I
never knew
well the good news is in about two years
there'll be 600 pounds of peace
that's a fun fun animal to have in your
home I've actually had pigs before in
Texas really yeah but they were on a far
they were like on our rescue farm so
they weren't like a they were a pet but
We rescued them I didn't have them from
like a you know piglet you didn't raise
them yeah I couldn't think of the word
thank you no no it's raise them see I I
do raise pigs for a living you do yeah
you do so much I really I'm very busy oh
wait so have you ever worked with any
dangerous animals or are they always
this cute they're these are dangerous
yeah these are very we could poop at any
time on your pants yeah I was uh one of
my many canceled shows uh uh I was on
I am I am the cooler when it comes to
television shows Kelly so good watch out
after this airs uh
and watch out for your jobs
uh no it was on it was a it was a show
called The Great Indoors on CBS and I
played I had a lot of animals on it and
uh and I we had a baby bear super sweet
and then one time it just decided to see
if you know I was edible and uh yeah it
bit me in the arm and uh they were like
just wear layers because they're you
know they're curious about everything
and I'm like curious to see what a human
being tastes like and uh it so the teeth
this is a great teeth aren't razor sharp
they're for crushing uh so it bit so
hard it didn't break skin or anything
because it was wearing oh I just let
this one go all right see you you're
free you're free it's babe uh you're
free run oh enjoy that carpet that's a
good one that's expensive that's out of
Kelly's home uh so that's yeah my
Wayfair collection so
yeah narcare spot it bit me and it in
the moment it bit me I I was holding it
and I dropped it and it landed did fine
and I was like I'm so sorry and the
Handler goes it drops out of trees 30
feet and uh what and goes for runs
afterwards because it'll be you'll be
he's great so oh my God and that's why
now at the home I have a nine foot
grizzly bear and uh look at that I mean
look at this they're so cute who cares
what I'm talking about right now because
look at this here's my question though
speaking of animals your wife posted um
a video of your dog's reaction to a cut
out of you so I want to show everyone
that yeah
oh
that's setting the pigs off does your
dog does your dog not like you it really
shows how my family doesn't like me and
uh yeah that dog well he does apparently
doesn't like me in two Dimensions uh
okay it scared him yeah so that cut out
now takes him for a walk each day and
he's fine he's much more used to it but
that's being back he's a nut job so he's
our he's we have three dogs I was gonna
say you do love animals though we have a
rabbit that lives in a shower and I'm
not kidding what well all right we had
two rabbits and one of them sadly passed
away and we were worried that it was
that something was going with the cage
so my wife put it in the shower and the
rabbit uh rejuvenated she's like Saint
Francis it it was great and now the sh
it just lives in the shower near the
kitchen and so when people come over and
they do their business there's a bunny
in the shower and so many of them come
out and go there's a rabbit in your
shower and you're like and I'm like
you're kidding and then I run in there
and I was like we had two rabbits and um
they would fight we found well we were
like what's going on I can't put my
female bunnies near each other they
fight we had two at each other oh and we
noticed one of their ear like one of
them was gnawing on the ear and then we
took them to the vet and the vet goes oh
it's what I thought yeah one of your
bunnies ate the testicle off of the
other bunny you told me this I feel like
we've had this conversation oh my gosh I
forgot about that yeah I had to separate
Mine mine's trying to get away right
well I mean if another bunny was trying
to remove its genitals then I would yeah
they don't touch each other we have them
separated yeah we didn't know we didn't
get that rule but I also don't have a
suite in a in a house with a bathtub
well it's super nice yeah it's a spot
treatment uh we do the steam bath for
the bunny the bunny's name is Junior
Joey
the pimware oh there they are they are
they're now producing their own
again no one's listening and that's that
makes me so happy
[Applause]
one of our favorite my personal
favorites you can see him in Star Girl
and on the CW and in crime scene Kitchen
on Fox he's a talented actor and a
brilliant host and a Super Rad Dad
please welcome John McCain
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you thank you
yet oh okay hold on I can do that how
about one of these how about this
gonna happen
hello red dads
Red Dead
hello Red Dead what
are you I am uh are you holding dead
fish no I'm very nauseous and so I was
like show must go on Kelly dead fish
yeah I brought some dead fish for you I
know you're a big fan of Montana
Rivers where you fish there I'm a fan of
live things too like they're alive but
they're all right well I brought some
live things with me okay so can we see
the animals that you brought I want to
see the animals no those are my kids oh
here
I noticed but I put holes in the box so
I'm not an animal yeah Red Dead thank
you red dad all right let's yeah let's
see what it is okay it'll be a surprise
are we taking the Box off I don't know
are we all right no let's do it no we're
not I'm gonna go on this side well
there's people for that that are wearing
the Kelly Clarkson show oh yeah here you
guys go
hey what's up guys
there you go all right
these are bald eagles and uh
oh there you go there you go guys yeah
this is a squishy and Tuck yeah these
are my own uh I live in Studio City so
that they're indigenous
cushy I mean tuck
cushy did you want one oh they're too
you know what they're fascinated by the
rad dads they're physics uh this is
perfect for rad dad so wait I I aren't
like penguins I feel like I've watched
this on the Discovery Channel aren't
people like the father's great father
about other networks okay no no no I
know you're syndicated I'm curious I've
[Laughter]
like I think they share the duties like
moms and dads yes they um they sit on
the eggs just as much as mom does
exactly and uh I did the same thing I
sat on my wife's womb for uh
which it turned out was a terrible
mistake they're not as hungry as uh as
usual hey they're not hungry you know
you usually I get them like a baked
perch and uh they're like this is
disgusting this is raw fish you know
what let's just let them go
enjoy yourselves just go wait they can't
hurt themselves right if they come off
of the don't all cats land on your feet
or some or their feet okay no no no what
are you talking about no I've heard that
if a cat like Falls or something the cat
falls they land on their feet oh my God
it's on the back I'm a mom I'm a mom you
gotta get it you gotta get it you gotta
get it you're gonna be fine
this is how they learn
anyway I see you guys are very excited
about my films
[Applause]
now look at this look how TV ready they
are I remember put an album cover right
here just like
this is
look I mean have you ever seen you're
set up they're set up this guy better
fall in line all right go over there oh
you're CR you are a crawler oh you're
going all the way around so about your
films
um
whoa this that guy you're crazy I don't
want you to die man okay so about your
films I don't know happily Becky and
happily yes Becky is made by uh it's a
great uh it's me and a wonderful actress
named Lulu Wilson and Kevin James
uh it is it is definitely not a comedy
and then uh the other one's called
happily uh directed by a guy named Ben
David grabinski and it's Mina wonderful
actor named uh Carrie Boucher and
Stephen Root who you've seen on Barry
and a thousand other things in His Radio
and uh but no one's listened to a thing
I've said it doesn't matter let's get
all the cats just move on to the red and
let's see what happens
it's fine take a sip oh wait that's mine
[Applause]
that's in April and I know you'll all go
to the film festival you're gonna love
it
it's fine it's fine it's a cat wait okay
wait Joel so card sharks card sharks is
back look um do you like being a Game
host is it fun what is a Game host a
gamer you're hosting a game I think it's
in the definition is in the name I think
it's game show
it's a game show host yeah game show we
give away cats and uh please don't die
it's gonna go great uh yeah you can win
look it yes it's you can win a lot of
money I can I can totally get you on the
show yeah okay uh but if you think about
it Kelly nobody has listened to a thing
we have said
in the last few minutes I did get you
something too um last time you were here
in our studio you had some emotional
support kittens um for your interview so
now Justin can can we bring them out
this is oh this is here we go it's not
kittens this time guys it's puppies oh
my gosh oh for real oh my goodness I
hadn't seen the puppies yet because they
know that I want to take all of them
home yeah no we should you should take
them home hey guys I'm here yeah I'm not
supposed
to but I couldn't oh you're not that
near okay okay well all of these puppies
are available for adoption through paw
Works go to our website for more
information so uh but don't you have to
adopt them all at once yeah you can't
just take one at a time I feel like my
mom does that she has like a billion
dogs they're amazing they're so sweet oh
my gosh they're all adorable this is a
dangerous time for me right now Joel
It's a danger you know no one's
listening to a word you've said I
haven't listened to it I've said I'm
supposed to be hosting a show and right
now I'm like I have a dog and two
children I'm single now I really
shouldn't get another dog why not you
know the great thing about these puppies
they stay this size these ones they're
this new breed they stay this size and
oh my gosh these are the this is well
I'm
almost I give you gifts I'll take I'll
take like three or four and when one of
them defecates on me it is going to be a
very exciting time oh you're gonna be
okay are you gonna be okay yeah you're
shaking a little bit he's like I can't
believe I'm on the Kelly Clarkson show
oh my gosh you guys I'm gonna end up I'm
gonna end up taking one yeah I mean I
brought you brought you a gift you did
did you maybe bring me one yes puppy
should get many things yes I did did you
I brought another thing Justin would you
please bring it out Justin oh there it
is
I brought that
you know early
uh you know it's fun to have puppies and
skeletons yeah uh now this is my grandpa
he passed away
his name was Roy uh don't worry I wanna
I want this skeleton to breathe safely
so oh my God that's kind of you yeah
you're gonna do that real quick there
you go it also promotes your masks which
uh yes I think we should we yeah well we
just try and keep everyone safe this is
this is not weird at all
but tell me about your new movie since
you're here oh no problem well I'm sure
people paying will be paying attention
to what I'm saying as we hold the cutest
animals on the planet uh it's called
happily yeah and it's about a um happily
married couple uh for 14 years who uh
and this is the jumping off point of the
movie
um we uh can't we act like newlyweds
still we um we have sex all the time so
and our and our friends hate us there
there we are in the bathroom at a
friend's house and someone's trying to
get in that's Carrie Boucher she's one
of the best actors I've ever worked with
it's directed by Ben David grabinski and
um it is uh it's like a it's like an
episode of Twilight's Zone with a lot of
sex it's also relationship goals I think
yeah yeah
it's not bad so the
how does your wife feel yeah why don't
you show a clip what the heck we did we
did we just showed the one where she's
killing someone in the background oh
perfect no how does your wife feel about
that well it's funny when people like
how does your wife feel and no one ever
goes because I've been in a bunch of
movies where I get killed yeah and like
tortured no one ever's like how did you
feel about that they don't even ask
about that so I oh uh I always like like
here's the deal and the uh she was like
she really liked the message and um
We're not gonna watch it with the kids
no uh but uh but uh that's why I married
the coolest person on the planet my wife
Sarah is like I don't know what I would
be I would be in this cage if I yeah
well I think there she is right there I
think you keep bringing things home that
can go in cages like you keep and she
said if you bring one more animal home I
did yes I she said if I brought one more
dog home that might be the end that
would tip it we uh we are going to be
married for 25 years this July five
years
remember it was a long time
like
I don't even know her middle name yeah
we met at a Kelly Clarkson concert
25 years ago it was a dinner theater
thing
or eight it was you're still fabulous
thank you thank you uh we sat with Simon
Cowell yes because I knew him is when I
was a kid yeah he was super fun told us
about his face look exactly the same
black T-shirt yeah black T-shirt a
little bit of chest hair popping out uh
my wife and I met on a movie set in
Seattle and her mom was an extra and her
brother was a production assistant and
they uh I was introduced to her I knew
who she was because she dated no one and
uh so then I we had a mutual friend and
I called my friend I said hey do you
think Sarah Williams will uh go out with
me and my friend was like
no and uh I got her number and I uh wore
her down I wore her down why why do you
think she didn't date anyone she's just
not interested yeah I mean she was like
wait is there a guy out there with
bunnies and a basketball jersey and five
thousand dogs yeah uh yeah I'm not
saying she has the greatest judgment on
the planet
uh but she is somehow she has agreed to
be married to me for 25 years amazing
yeah no it's it's great we got divorced
three times and got remarried someone
started clapping I was like wait what uh
no but as you know I have seven wives so
yeah cool yeah let's start that rumor
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]